oh
your classrooms
is
this
it oh
do you like to teach me tonight
is
yes
is
come on
problems
is
is
2.3
for the days
his name was
so now i'm singing
is
is
is
i think you encapsulated uh
many aspects of me there
i'm a bit sad now
um
uh it's true i'm not the only one who's
been inspired by how much you've done
and in fact uh i spent the last a few
weeks very very ninja slide uh like
collecting messages from people all over
the school and we've left the school
already uh we got a little book for you
except i was i was so stressed out about
remembering the lyrics that i forgot to
bring with me so
so i'm going to give it to you
afterwards but the whole school says
thank you
you i thought um did a better job at
scaring you people
uh
they're not mutually exclusive
categories of the house
right oh well uh
all i can say well i need to keep this
book close to my
bedroom every night so i can stay awake
all night and not stressed about
anything else
but
thank you very much that was just
fantastic
those lyrics
yeah
very passionate mathematics the geometry
et cetera and past mathematicians
i hope that somehow we can see your
names up in light and years to come that
your name will be there in mathematics i
hope you really it'd be really great
that you've taken that bold step forward
many have done in the past so
see how we go
was a very good mathematician so
i can it's easy to be i'd love to be
wrong and like you people to show me
that i can be wrong so thank you
you